les battements afro et la musique afro ont commencé à
faire le tour du monde et vous en jouez
ce n'est pas étrange de le voir
dans tous les coins du monde ces jours-ci
vous savez et je suis comme pourquoi pas l'animation
aussi pourquoi pas le film vous savez merci
asseyez-vous
un  d'entre vous
n'avez pas rendu vos devoirs
et ces livres
n'ont pas de noms dessus
hein
[Musique]
qui était-ce
donc calabanda est mon devoir a été notre
projet phare en studio
et après avoir fait un color bandit mes
devoirs nous avons appris beaucoup de  des choses
sur la production et les limites de la
production en afrique comment pouvons-nous nous développer
comment pouvons-nous sortir comment pouvons-nous
quelles erreurs avons-nous commises comment pouvons-nous
former plus d'artistes et c'est ce que nous
avons fait ces dernières années et
dans le  processus c'est comme ça que j'aime aussi
ces autres projets internationaux
c'est juste une plate-forme mais il n'y a aucune
raison pour qu'un
studio africain ou un
individu africain ne puisse pas s'élever au-dessus de disney
ne peut pas devenir plus grand qu'eux je ne
vois aucune raison pour laquelle
merci